investigators to France to assist with
the recorder download and read out
within 30 days of each crash the
Indonesian and Ethiopian authorities
issued a preliminary report regarding
their respective investigations NTSB
provided technical comments for each of
these reports last week miss Schultz
traveled to Addis to meet with Ethiopian
officials regarding the investigation
and in the coming weeks the US team will
return to Ethiopia to work further with
those authorities because the u.s. is
the state of design and certification of
the 737 we are also examining the design
certification process is a part of our
participation in these foreign lead
investigations our review is continuing
and if we uncover safety deficiencies we
are prepared to quickly issue safety
recommendations aimed at correcting such
deficiencies our commitment to the
traveling public and especially to those
families affected by these two tragic
events is to bring all of our experience
and expertise in support of the
international effort to determine why
these accidents occurred and most
importantly to ensure that no similar
accident like these occurs again thank
you we'll be happy to answer your
questions Thank You mr. chair Simone now
recognize acting Minister dan Elwell for
five minutes
chairman Larson ranking member graves
chairman DeFazio ranking member graves
thank you for the opportunity today to
discuss aviation safety and the issues
surrounding the Boeing 737 max I also
want to take this opportunity to express
my sincerest condolences on behalf of
the entire FAA to the victims and their
families of both Ethiopia flight 302 and
Lion Air flight 610 I want to emphasize
at the outset that the FAA welcomes
scrutiny that helps make us better that
is how our global leadership and
aviation safety will endure
as you all know the FAA grounded the
u.s. 737 max fleet on march 13th 2019
that decision was based upon crash site
findings and satellite data that
together indicated some similarities
between the Ethiopian and Indonesian
accidents that warranted further
investigation of the possibility of a
shared cause and I will focus my remarks
today on events since the grounding in
particular the various ongoing reviews
of the FAS processes and the work being
done towards safely returning the 737
max to service our commitment to safety
and fact-based
data-driven decision-making has been the
guiding principle in all of this after
the grounding several reviews were
initiated to assess the FAA s processes
separate from evaluating any particular
technical fix for the 737 max on march
19th secretary Chow asked the Department
of Transportation's inspector general to
conduct an audit of this Boeing 737 max
eight certification with the goal
specifically to compile an objective and
detailed history of the activities that
led to certification that out audit is
ongoing with the cooperation of the FAA
secretary Chow on March 25th announced
the establishment of a special committee
to review the FAA s procedures for the
certification of new aircraft including
the Boeing 737 max the special committee
is an independent body whose findings
and recommendations will be presented
directly to the secretary and the FAA
Administrator on April 2nd the FAA
launched a joint Authority's technical
review chatter to review the
certification of the 737 max automated
flight control system the jetter is
chaired by former NTSB chairman
Christopher Hart and comprises a team of
us experts and international aviation
authorities the 737 max returned to
service is not contingent on these
reviews rather the reviews are geared
towards developing systemic improvements
for the future now talk about the FAA
Zephyr --tz-- to safely return the 737
max to service here and abroad as the
FAA discussed in an informational notice
for 737 max operators on March 20th
boeing has been working on a service
bulletin that would specify the
installation of new flight control
computer operational program software
and has developed flight crew training
related to this software on April 12th
the FAA met with safety representatives
of the three us-based commercial
airlines that fly the Boeing 737 max as
well as the pilot unions for those
airlines and this unprecedented meeting
was an opportunity for the FAA to hear
individual views from operators and
pilots the FAA recently solicited public
comment on a draft report prepared by
the FAA s Boeing 737 max flight
standardization board that board
consists of pilots and we use it to
evaluate Boeing's proposed training
associated with Boeing's proposed
software enhancements for the 737 max on
may 6th we initiated a multi-agency
technical advisory board or tab to
review Boeing's MCAS software update and
system safety assessment the tab
includes experts from the US Air Force
NASA Volpe and the FAA and none of these
experts were involved in the original
certification of the 727 max the tabs
recommendations will directly inform our
decisions on the 737 max fleets return
to service and next week on May 23rd the
FAA will host a meeting of directors
general of civil aviation authorities
from around the world to discuss the FAA
s activities toward ensuring the safe
return of the 737 max to service this
meeting is part of the FAA s efforts to
work with other civil aviation
authorities to address specific concerns
related to the 70s
max in keeping with the FAA xong
standing cooperation with our
international partners as our work
continues I want to offer this assurance
in the u.s. the 737 max will return to
service
only when the FAA is analysis of the
facts and technical data indicate that
it's safe to do so
this concludes my prepared statement
welcome your questions thank you very
much for your statements both of you
we're now going to move to member
questions each member will be recognized
for five minutes
and I'll start by recognizing myself
administrator Elwell this week the Wall
Street Journal reported the FA and FA
internal review tentatively determined
senior agency officials did not
participate in or monitor critical
safety assessments of the 737 max flight
control system also noted the fa
deferred to boyens early safety
classification and the subsequent
analysis of potential hazards were
performed with limited oversight by the
agency is that report accurate and if
accurate what explanation is it if they
have for I guess falling down on the job
microphone thank you for that question
chairman Larsen I think you're talking
about the Wall Street Journal article of
yesterday and I we take all those those
articles and those charges or reports
seriously but frankly I there's nothing
in that article that led me to anything
that I'm aware of so so we'll we'll
certainly see what we can find out about
it but and and I'll ask my colleague
Earl if he if he's aware of before you
get to mr. Lawrence so the article
reported that the FAS own assessment
determined tentatively that senior
agency officials were not involved in
this assessment I'm not aware of an
internal assessment Florence reached
that conclusion
we're I'm not aware of the internal
assessment that the article refers to I
was okay well we have some homework and
you do too but I think it does relate to
set of questions with regards the Oda
and the use of the the Oda process mr.
Ryu previously stated that was reported
that you stated that a full reversion of
certification activities to the FA would
require 10,000 additional FA inspectors
and 1.8 billion dollars and I'm here to
argue whether it's one more one less
than that but has the FA considered
moving back to the previous designated
engineering representative system away
from the AR system and what would that
cost me chairman Larson I don't know
what that cost would be I know that
there are a number of investigations and
audits as we as several opening
statements have have pointed out that
are designed to look at the process I
also know that our risk-based data
driven systems approach has as a ranking
member grave stated as lead four to the
u.s. safest system in history in the
world I'm very very careful to make sure
that the results of any inquiries
investigations audits bring us
actionable information I mean as as I
said we welcome those investigations we
welcome the audits they make us better
but at this point to say that we're
willing to go back to something before
we've gone through those investigations
I'm not prepared to say that I really
want to see what these investigations
and these audits have to say about our
processes so the current system with
authorized representatives however has
Oda participants reporting I understand
to managers as opposed to engineers and
under the de our system the Oda designee
is reporting to engineers
[Music]
are you through your assessment looking
at whether a change from reporting to
engineers who can who can monitor
engineers versus managers who are
looking more at budgets are you looking
at whether that process needs to be
changed is that gonna be part of they
say the the blue-ribbon Commission's
look sir I'm not aware of any limit on
what we're gonna look at we're gonna
look at everything I would say that the
organization designation authority Oda
as it exists today is a process that's
developed over decades we've had Oda in
one form of another since the beginning
of the FAA we've had delegation of
authority since 1927 it's the concept
isn't new it's the administration of it
in my mind if we have robust oversight
and we have all the protections in place
to guard against conflicts of interest
or undue pressure which I believe we
currently have it's a good system but it
can always be made better I mean that's
that's what we're all about
and I'll just conclude but on that point
though that I guess putting the faith in
the evolution of the system to get to
where we are today isn't necessarily a
positive assessment of the system that
we have just because it has evolved
since 1927 doesn't mean it has evolved
to the place where it needs to be or
should be and it perhaps has over
evolved in this case well so with that
I'll yield 5 minutes to ranking member
and graves at Louisiana Tech mr.
chairman raise your hand if you have a
pilot's license in this room raise your
hand if you have been flying a plane
when the stick shakers gone off the
stick shakers gone off so wait could you
do that again hands up snake shakers
gone off so three of you for you and and
and did any of you not turn the plane
around or come back and land when
happened raise your hand if you kept
going
Thank You mr. mr. mr. chairman I I just
want to make note that no one raised
their hand in terms of continuing the
fight and the reason I ask that question
is that is that in both accidents stake
takers went off and and and and the
planes didn't turn around and I just I
find that interesting that I find that
interesting that that the that in this
case the planes didn't turn around mr.
Elwell there's been a lot of confusing
information in the news media regarding
what happened and and I've read a few
times where the there has been
referenced to quote self-certification
could you clarify that do companies
self-certified they're their own
aircraft mr. graves no sir they don't we
don't have a program of
self-certification ODA empowers private
individuals at a company that has an Oda
program to do certain tasks and make
certain decisions they are delegated
with that authority that we then oversee
and this isn't something that we give
lightly to to be granted an Oda is a
privilege that a company earns we have
about 79 or 80 of them I think and it's
important to note that the vetting that
is required of the individuals in an Oda
program in the Oda program itself is
very thorough and robust and to your
point mr. chairman we're not resting on
that we don't we don't ever stay static
on anything in the FAA safety-related so
we'll continue to look at that and I I
have to my right mr. Lawrence who is our
resident expert on on Oda and the
process if if I can allow him to
elaborate thank you I'd like to build
one point under mr. L wills comments and
it goes back to the chairman Larson's
comment earlier in in an Oda system
we don't have engineers reporting to
just managers we have engineers
reporting to engineers and those
engineers are all have to be approved
and vetted by the FAA so the head of an
Oda is an engineer who has all those
skills and experiences that has to be
approved by FAA engineers as well thank
you mr. Elwell another question again a
lot of a lot of interesting articles
regarding the the potential ungrounded
of the of the max could you describe the
steps that that that the plane would
have to go through in order to be
ungrounded or to be able to fly again
yes sir so I think just to go back a
little bit it's important to to lay the
groundwork for it we we grounded the
u.s. fleet when we had the data to
establish a potential causal link
between two accidents that is the
justification for grounding and it's
important that you establish a link
because you then have what you need to
mitigate to unground or to remove the
prohibition order so what we will do is
we will receive Boeing's application for
a design modification to the mcat system
and we will thoroughly evaluate that and
their system safety analysis we will
evaluate the training required to bring
that to certify that new software system
and once we have made our analysis we've
consulted with the tab which by the way
is a third party third set of eyes that
I think this committee recommended a
month or two ago that that should be
employed in this instance and we agree
and we initiated the tab and once we
have absolutely convinced of the safety
return to service and we'll do it
chairman Sam well very quick yes or no
do you
that there are processes programs or
procedures that domestic airlines follow
that may have prevented these based on
your preliminary prevented these
accidents based on your preliminary
reports ranking member graves I
apologize
maybe it's my ears maybe it's the
acoustics in the room I'm not having I'm
having difficulty hearing the question
what I'd love to come back to it but we
will we will I recognize chair DeFazio
for five minutes I thank mr. chairman
administrator Elwell we were both in the
Air Force you were pilot I wasn't but my
understanding is that the Air Force has
a minimum of two angle-of-attack sensors
on its planes and sometimes as many as
four does that sound right to you sorry
there are different numbers depending on
the size of the aircraft right but never
one as far as I know never one right the
planes
I flew in the Air Force had at least two
okay then the is the MKS a safety
critical system in your opinion I didn't
make that designation but it seems to me
that yes it is okay then why would it
trigger with a single point of failure I
mean isn't that kind of standard that we
never have a safety critical system
trigger off a single point of failure
yes sir a single point of failure means
that if that component or that part of
the aircraft fails it will lead to an
accident well the case in this case it
led to triggering the MCATs which is
safety critical here let me let me read
you something this I got this from a
very very experienced 737 pilot if M
Cass has not stopped by the pilots in in
the at the completion of two full M cast
cycles ten seconds pause five seconds
ten seconds horizontal stabilizer is
that or very close to the full nose-down
limit of travel at this point the pilots
do not have enough elevator authority to
overcome the horizontal stabilizer and
the nose the aircraft will continue to
fall the aircraft is no longer
controllable and pitch the only possible
recovery
the aircraft nose up so the horizontal
stabilizer moves to the flyable position
this pilot would characterize and MKS
runaway is having high potential to
result in a drastic abrupt manoeuvre
that sounds pretty radical I mean now
why in this case the argument is the
pilots are supposed to correct the
system but until after Lyon air the
pilots didn't know the system was
installed was that correct yes sir
and the pilots also didn't know that the
disagree light didn't work unless you
bought the optional package of of safety
which included more and another set you
had both the disagree light and then you
had I guess digital gauges that showed
what the angle of attack sensors were
weren't seeing or feeling or doing so
when did the FAA become aware that the
disagree light wasn't working which had
been on I guess all previous models of
the 737 sir if I could go back to the
737 pilot yeah so I wasn't a 737 pilot
in my commercial days but I had the
opportunity to fly to Macs in a month or
so ago and I would I would offer on the
mechanics of it that at the moment that
a pilot and were trained our entire
careers a moment you feel the airplane
doing something you didn't command it to
do you instinctively trim in the other
direction and if it doesn't work you do
a memory procedure called runaway stab
to him so they I'm not going to take
issue with his comments about to bursa
VM cast what it might do but I know I so
that's that's that's a that's a elapsed
time period of 20 seconds yeah I I it's
20 seconds I mean that's pretty quick
and if you're at a low altitude I think
you know pretty but let's go back to the
the issue of when the FAA was informed
by Boeing Boeing knew that I believe
about a year before they informed the
FAA that the disagree light didn't work
so sir our we've looked at this and
software engineers discovered the
anomaly and the anomaly was tied to the
EM cast software that part of the change
of the end but but the question or just
no I I get that I mean we can get into
details but the point is a year elapsed
before Boeing told the FAA what actions
did the FAA take at that point in time
did you consider that inappropriate
behavior by Boeing so I'm concerned that
it took a year and we're looking into
that and we're gonna fix that once we
learned that the light was not operable
then we made the decision that it is not
a safety critical display it's not a
safety critical display it is advisory
there are no actions that the pilot
takes to an AOA disagree light and so it
did not olivewood would alert them to
that that whatever the runaway problem
is due to is due to at that point the
angle of attack indicators actually the
the notice of that is tactile one yoke
is shaking and the other isn't that is
by definition right away disagree so the
light is advisory okay then why is it
there at all
it's good for maintenance so if you get
an AOA disagree light in flight you know
to tell maintenance on the ground hey
check one of these is not calibrated
correctly or is good so then really you
don't think it's significant that Boeing
didn't tell people the system was in the
plane and didn't tell people that the
disagree like didn't work none of that
was oh actually probably matter I think
that's an issue certain we're gonna look
into it it shouldn't take a year for us
to find out that that discovery was made
I appreciate that and I really would
want to know the answer and in fact
there the Dallas news and this is off of
a tape recording so I think it's
accurate
this was pilots talking to after they
found out that there was an
caste system in the plane after lion air
talking to a Boeing engineer and they
said why wouldn't you tell us about the
system
I don't know that understanding this
system would have changed the outcome he
said in a million miles you're gonna
maybe fly this airplane maybe you're
once gonna see this ever we try not to
overload the crews with information
that's unnecessary
I mean do we really think that the that
was unnecessary that that it wasn't even
in the manual and they didn't know about
it I mean there's a lot of stuff in that
manual that you don't really need to
know yeah well mr. chairman I can't
comment on that conversation and I think
you were quoting Boeing I as a pilot
when when I first heard about this I
thought that there should have been more
text in the manual about EMS I agree mr.
Lawrence in response to the Chairman you
said that the engineer reports to an
engineer can that engineer to which the
report is rendered be also be a manager
at Boeing they would be a manager and
are in the organizational delegation
organization could they be have
managerial status at Boeing and they're
paid by Boeing is that correct
they are paid by Boeing that is correct
okay thank you
just one other question now we've had 14
if we could put up on the screen the the
flight deck 67 flight deck 17 well I
thought we couldn't put it up in any way
I have it here you can't see it but
you'd be familiar with it we're getting
used to our new electronics but when you
think of it there it is now pretty
different airplanes they're you know
they're computer screens GPS
everything's digital you know the other
is analog you know very very different
planes and this is 14 variations later
and I think we've got to question the
system where if you I think if you took
the 737 100 and compared it to a max you
would say wow these are different types
but we sort of gradually got there
kept moving and moving and moving
through 14 variations and never
determined that it would have to go
through a more rigorous process as a new
type and including pilot retraining and
those sorts of things I mean doesn't
that raise some questions about how you
kind of get this creep over 14
variations over however many years that
is 67 42 years sorry I know that begs
the question I would remind though that
the amended type certificate of the max
was amending the ng and if you had the
ng in the max side by side then you
could see the similarities there so
close as to as to be amended it wasn't
the ng amended from the 900 correct was
amended from the 8/7 they say I had one
so I mean that's kind of its kind of a
creep that seems to me I think there's a
question there we should look at well
and and as I said before that in the
beginning of your questions we welcome
that that examination if if if there's
something wrong with the extension of a
family and of course that's something
that that the 737 has multiple
iterations but again we're certifying to
the last to the last one okay all right
Thank You mr. chairman thank you I know
we have a five-minute roll them indulge
the chair I have a eight and a half
minutes and I want to afford that for
the ranking member of the committee as
well so recognize mr. graves the ranking
member for updating ethics Thank You mr.
trim can we bring that back up the on
the screen is we keep we keep focusing
on the angle of attack indicator so if
you see on the right there 737 max that
that screen in front of both the pilot
and the co-pilot with the blue above and
the brown below that's your primary
angle of attack indicator that's your
artificial horizon every aircraft out
there has to have that to be certified
the one on the left the older version
that's digital on the right the one on
the left is what we call analog and if
you see the circle in front of both the
pilot and the co-pilot and there's white
above and black below it's the same
thing
that's your artificial horizon that's
your primary angle-of-attack indicate in
fact all my years of flying I don't
think I've ever had an actual what we're
talking about angle of attack indicator
in any of the aircraft I've ever flown
but what's interesting too is and we we
fail to and I go back to this you got to
know how to fly the plane fly the plane
in Ethiopia Airlines incident you can
look outside that's the critical angle
of attack indication right there look
outside the airplane when you find it
you can tell if you're at a critical
angle of attack because you're gonna be
pitched up you're gonna be you're
getting close to a stall situation those
are your two main angle of attack
indicators first of all look outside
when you're flying the plane and second
of all look at your your artificial
horizon and I guess my first question is
for administrator all well and at this
point we know and we always know there's
so many other things to look at in in
these investigations you know not just
if a certification activities with the
737 max but many many other things and
what I want to get to is the preliminary
report shows that there were a lot of
misidentifications on what was occurring
in the aircraft and misapplications of
safety procedures and and training in
itself and is a pilot and I want you to
talk to us as a pilot can you provide
this some context as to what actions or
inactions by the pilots or the airline
for that manner also require some close
examination in the course of this in
this investigation thank you for that
question
as a pilot I mentioned a little bit
earlier that in the u.s. training
focuses on hand flying manual flying
there are other parts of the world and
other countries that focus on flight
control management but in the u.s. from
the first training you do as a pilot air
force for me but it's the same in civil
it's flying the aircraft
and what was going on it's already been
pointed out that there was an a false
indication of a stall immediately
recognizable to the train pilot as a
false indication because one yoke was
shaking the other wasn't what concerns
me about the the data from the flight
data recorder is the apparent lack of
recognition of runaway stab trim runaway
stab trim is taught at the earliest
stages of aircraft that have stab trim
motors and it is so important to
chairman to Fazio's point about time
elapse time it's so important that you
don't pull out a checklist you don't
open and look at what next it's
memorized and you're tested on it all
the time and you turn off those stab
trim motors in the lion air accident
it's significant that even though the
airplane was pitching against the pilots
commands
that's classic runaway stab trim the
stab trim motors in 13 minutes were
never turned off and I think you made
the point sir in your remarks that in
the case of the ethiopian air flight
they did turn them off although they
didn't adhere to the emergency ad that
we put out on november 8th they did turn
the stab trims off but they never
controlled their airspeed and then
subsequently about a minute out before
the end of the flight they turned them
back on both of those things are
unfortunate obviously and I have to
point out in deference to my colleague
here to my left chairman some well these
investigations are ongoing and as you
said there are so many pieces to any
accident I've never looked at an
accident where there weren't three or
four or five links of the chain any one
of which if it hadn't gone wrong the
plane would have survived so we know
that there's going to be and there are
factors but as a pilot as you asked me
that's that's what I saw that the lack
of control and the speed on an Ethiopian
in the
the inability the apparent not doing the
stab trim cutout switch procedure we
come back to and we keep coming back to
it and forgetting you know once they set
those throttles to full power
they never [ __ ] him and I've used that
analogy the analogy before when you're
in a car and you're speeding towards a
brick wall
full speed you're gonna take your foot
off the gas that's what most people
would do but they accelerated right
through
there's certified maximum speed of a of
the max eight and just kept on
accelerating throughout the entire
process that aircraft kept accelerating
and when you get those kind of pressures
against the control services it makes it
very very hard to to do manually and you
know and again this comes back to so
many times pilot training this is what
worries me more than anything else and
and I hate to disparage you know another
country and and and what their pilot
training is but that's what scares me in
all of this it's climbing on an aircraft
or an airline you know that is there's
outside US jurisdiction I know what we
have in the US and I know we're capable
of and I know the quality of our pilots
and the quality what they have to go
through to get to that point and and I
just think it's you know it just bothers
me here we are we just we continue to
tear down our system based on you know
what has happened in in in another
country to other countries and
particularly given the qualifications
and you know what we're learning about
the training standards but that last
part was port headed toriel than
anything else was chairman I yield back
Thank You ranking graves now recognized
rep represent Norton for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman we don't tear
down our system we want to restore
confidence in our system miss y'all and
I'm sure you are concerned that this is
impressive
record may well be shattered I regarded
as a purpose of this
as your answers to help us if we can
restore confidence in a system and by
the way most members maybe except me use
every single every single week to go
back and forth to the Congress so that
this loss of confidence this despite
this wonderful 10-year record seems to
have been shattered and so just let me
ask you a question
preliminary mr. I think most members of
the public after one crash would have
said oh that's unusual two crashes why
did it take so long compared to other
countries that made the decision almost
immediately after the Ethiopian Airlines
accident in fact because I recall it the
president made the announcement but as
is what he probably was perhaps
pre-empting the FAA but that's where the
announcement came from if anything it
signals the importance that somebody
should speak up so I I think the public
which will be interested in this hearing
wants to know why did it take you so
long after the Ethiopian Airlines
accident explained that to this
committee mrs. Norton thank you for that
question
the FAA is a data-driven risk-based
systems approach to all things safety
when we take an action and whether it's
the grounding of an aircraft or an air
worthiness directive or other countries
weren't data driven that's a difference
between you in other countries I can't
speak to the decision-making of other
country
I can tell you this a number of
countries that that grounded their 737
max fleets called us immediately after
and asked what data we had several
countries asked after grounding their
fleets what are we gonna eat that means
that they were looking at real time real
life evidence even if it may have
contradicted the data are you still as
reliant on data as you were then
compared to other countries today would
you be reliant only on data well ma'am
that's a great question we made our
decision to ground the aircraft when we
had the data that linked the two flights
data to length of flights but we weren't
just sitting waiting for the cockpit
voice recorder or the flight data
recorder we were examining as the
regulator of our 737 max sleep what's
going on with our fleet and we drew data
on 57,000 flights and we were talking
constantly with our neighborhood
neighbor to the north I was after the
first after after from the first
accident but up through Ethiopia to find
out are we
the the the fleet that I am responsible
for regulating are they experiencing any
anomalies and there were zero zero and
fifty seven thousand flights can I ask
you this mr. oh I'm sorry could I ask
you this then okay again we see reliance
and I would say perhaps over reliance on
data did the president make this call or
did the FAA make this call a phase
safety regulator FAA made the call - he
only made the announcement is that what
you saying you were prepared to make
that call yourself after the second
accident yes ma'am okay he preempted you
but you were prepared to do it you
wouldn't have waited for a third
accident the data told you after the
second accidents ma'am yes ma'am could I
ask you or mister
does the FAA mandate pilot training on
all of its systems and which and this
was news to me in which the pilot is
considered the redundancy for the
systems failure most of us didn't know
that the pilot was so considered mr.
Hall you have to take that question for
the record I'm sorry sir you'll have to
take a question for the record okay
and recognize mr. Mitchell were sir
Mitchell for five minutes
thank you sir chair the effectiveness
the success of the aviation system in
North America has been based on safety
reliability and transparency of
decision-making both in terms of
certification of aircraft pilot
qualifications and when there are
incidents
mr. well you'll really call last week
there was a briefing from members of the
committee on the 737 max certification I
asked a question I asked what this is
what the FAA had done in the process of
reviewing and certifying the EM caste
system to be honest with you sir I got a
hold of scripts what the system didn't
didn't do but didn't get answer to my
question and no point did I and they
were greeted by this DeFazio notes this
Wall Street Journal article so I'll ask
the question again I'll ask it for the
record
and I will ask you submit in writing to
the committee what were the steps the
FAA took in reviewing the MKS system and
the accompanying training because I've
asked it now three times and I've blown
with you sir with all due respect I
haven't gotten a direct answer and the
committee deserves it we will get that
answer for you sir I hope you deeply
appreciate it and I'd like it straight
up what did you what was the engagement
in this system throughout the process in
detail don't worry about boring me I
don't believe that the chair is gonna be
bored by reading this I certainly am NOT
we need to understand that because
there's a critical component of this I
can write I can assure you that the MKS
system was examined and certified
because it was a new system to the max
it was we retained it and we we had the
oversight of that and we certified it
well you may recall I asked the question
didn't get an answer that there was
anywhere close to SAS
- right appreciated let's transition to
as noted 737 Max's phone 57,000 flights
in North America without an incident
part of the difference is the training
of the Aviators deflect pilots I mean
I've done some structure I don't have a
pilot's license I don't have time but
there's clearly made to me first thing
you a v8 you fly the plane then you
navigate then you communicate
so yeah I see a stick shaker they made
me do it it's interesting
I'm concerned that and I'm trying to be
respectful because they're deceased the
pilot commanded the Ethiopian air was 29
years old and was reported to have 80
100 and change hours of flight now let
me give you some examples close friends
of mine are commercial pilots flew for
major corporations is 58 at 17,000 hours
the gentlemen 63 also flew from major
corporations in private flight six is 63
years old it's 20,000 hours the second
their first officer had 361 hours have
you I mean do we not have concerns with
not only the training of pilots in other
nations but the reliability of their
logs to try and claim 80-100 hours at
age 29 how many pilots do you know have
twin endur'd have have over 8,000 hours
of 29u servation mr. Mitchell I don't I
don't know anybody 29 years old that has
80 100 hours but I'm not going to say
that that's not possible and the answer
to your question is do we want to
examine and take a very hard look at the
training standards globally yes
absolutely we've been involved the u.s.
has led on pilot training for many years
and we do that at the International
Civil Aviation Organization the UN body
that provides the guidance for standards
around the world I think it needs to be
an issue that we address with ICAO and
as we deal with this because clearly
where the disparity is concerning to me
one quick question I guess I would also
ask you to assert this the record cuz
times gonna run short in reference to
my colleagues question part of the
reason for the delay or the delayed
response United States is we got our
data from Canada do we not indirectly
yes sir
we didn't have the data the same level
of specificity that Canada had because
we don't have access to that system that
they use for their traffic control
correct we we do have access to it sir
but Canada got it first because it came
from a company that the air traffic
services in Canada I submit that whole
process that whole time I'm writing to
the committee please yes sir
well thank you sir one last comment I
believe that we've got the most advanced
aviation system world if I'm multiple
factors that contribute to this terrible
tragedy
one of which will be we didn't see
things that could have come up it's hard
to sometimes have a crystal ball but
when you do recertify this aircraft I
will be among the first to buy a ticket
to fly in the plane because I have faith
in her aviation system I have faith in
the FAA I have faith in Boeing in the
aircraft they fly AB I will not fly it
somewhere to make the point that we have
to trust our aviation system thanks very
much I yield back
Thanks thank you and now recognize
symbol of Penske for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman sitting here in
front of the family of a victim of one
the crashes of a 737 max and looking at
the pictures of the victims it's crystal
clear that the with the responsibility
of the FAA the NTSB and our committee is
right now we need to get to the bottom
of what happened so we can do whatever
we can to ensure the safety of air
passengers and from what we know so far
it seems to me at least although there
sounds like there may be have been other
factors but it seems that something went
wrong with the FAA s safety
certification of the 737 max in 346
people died we need to figure out what
went wrong if it was a certification
process itself we need to fix it to
avoid or repeat it was the problem the
lack of compliance with the process and
we have to hold accountable whoever it
was
that was not compliant the FAA and/or
Boeing in addition further steps must be
taken to ensure compliance now where
this is not a legal proceeding here and
I know that we're in the early stages of
the investigation of the crashes and
certification of the max but stories
we've heard about the process of
certification so far are troubling the
guiding principle of the FAA and
manufacturers must be safety not getting
a highly valued plane out more quickly a
question was raised earlier by chairman
de Fazio about why the 737 max was not
required to get its own type certificate
to me this is very troubling seems to me
that because it did have to get its own
type certificate it could move more
quickly through the process now I'm not
a pilot and I'll defer to the pilots on
this committee when it comes to issues
of their experience as pilots but I am a
mechanical engineer I know that this
plane Boeing needed to compete with
Airbus they in order to have a more
fuel-efficient planes they put new
engines on the plane the engines had to
be put further forward on the wings
these changes in aerodynamics caused the
need for the MKS system and it seems to
me that the MKS system fundamentally
changes the way the Boeing 737 flies how
is this not a major change that required
a new type certificate well thank you
for that question mr. Lipinsky and I'm
I'm I'm glad you asked it because and I
appreciate that you're an engineer
actually the MKS was put into the 737
max for the opposite reason it doesn't
make it flight differently the end
was put designed into the airplane to
make it fly and feel for the pilots
exactly like the ng yes but it was it
was a it was a change it was a
fundamental change was its how how it
flies I understand was put in there to
try to make it fly the same way but the
system itself was a change
so the MCATs was added to a system that
was on the that is on the ng called the
speed trim system it is and I'm not an
engineer but it is a layer below a
software layer below the speed trim
system and as you said the MCATs was put
in because the engines were brought the
CG a little bit forward on the airplane
it the test flights demonstrated that in
a high angle of attack regime the yoke
didn't feel the same to the pilots as
the ng the MKS pushed the nose over so
that controllability and the feel in the
yoke would be the same and the flight
test pilots deemed that it was identical
and then the flight sanitization board
pilots which were actually line pilots
that we enlisted to fly both planes
found came to the same conclusion well
I'm hopeful that this was not a
situation where the desire was just to
get the plane out more quickly that it
wasn't a situation where safety was not
the priority because that must be the
priority as I said for the FAA for the
manufacturer safety must be the priority
I understand how important Boeing is is
an American company but safety must
always come first
sorry I couldn't agree more thank you
sir represents been known for five
minutes
Thank You mr. chairman and as before I
begin I too want to extend my sincere
condolences and regrets the members of
the family who are here today can't
imagine what you're going through and
thank you for being here very grateful
that you're here my first question is to
mr. Elwell can you help me understand
describe a little in more
a little bit more detail the FAs
delegation Authority what are the things
we delegate one of the things that we
don't delegate those things that we do
delegate how does the FAA oversee the
actions of designee x' just general
thank you thank you sir for that
question the key word in your question
detail begs that after I introduce that
I'm like to hand off the detail of the
ODA to Earl who is our resident expert I
will just start by saying the
organizational designation authority as
it's come to be known Oda is a
long-standing principle and
certification and it is a way in which
the FAA leverages the expertise within
the manufacturing entity it's very
important we understand that without
leveraging their engineering expertise
it would be virtually impossible to have
the system that we have today so as far
as the details of how the Oda is
administered Earl I appreciate that and
I appreciate it's a long-standing
process but the I think the public would
like to know so that they can have some
level of confidence that the FAA is
doing the job we expect them to do what
is delegated what is not how do we
oversee that amazing so thank you for
the question because I think there is a
lot of misunderstanding of our
delegation process I like to simplify
our cert process in four key areas and
the first and foremost is setting the
standards what are the rules and
requirements for any design to me next
or another layer of test protocols and
standing and standards so it's how
you're going to show compliance the
third level is the actual doing of the
tests and the calculations and then the
fourth is the overview of all those
results and the approval only in that
third level the actual doing of a test
is where delegation is used FAA is fully
responsible for setting the standards
that all tests must come
lieth and setting the standards for the
minimum safety for that aircraft and
then reviewing it all in the end we
never give up that authority we take
advantage of the expertise of the people
who are actually building and designing
the aircraft to assist us and reviewing
those tests and those procedures
particularly on things that have been
done over and over and over again over
many years
I want to highlight that it took us five
years and over a hundred and ten
thousand man-hours to certify the 737
max I don't think that was a quick
process or just cursory review we apply
the same rigorous standards on whether
it's a derivative design or original
design and I'm proud of my team
for their abilities and their expertise
and reviewing any certification project
thank you thank you mr. Lawrence our
next question is for chairman son well
if you would just help us help me
understand over the last maybe two or
three decades you know what what's the
state of commercial airline safety here
in the United States give us if you
would a brief sketch in a minute in 12
seconds well I I think generally
speaking the state of the airline
industry in the in the United States
over the last few decades has
increasingly gotten safer and safer but
as it was pointed out earlier we had one
fatality in the past decade one is too
many and of course we have the families
of the Kogan 3407 crash here they there
was 50 lives lost there so it's it's
good but good is not good enough and
then one final question it's been
mentioned that we don't we can't control
necessarily some of the the pilot
training protocols abroad are there any
mechanisms if any that we have at our
disposal to ensure that other countries
you know do have do require their pilots
to have the training that we feel is
appropriate and if
what are those mechanisms yes ICAO
International Civil Aviation
Organization outlines the standards and
recommended practices for member states
to follow there are 193 states that that
are subscribers to signatories to to
ICAO so and you can get us further
information on that as well we're also
reminded subcommittee that we've asked
through a bipartisan letter to the do
TIG for the International pilot training
standards and some other information as
well we get that we'll share with the
full committee recognize I represent
Cohen for five minutes thank you sir
express my root it sadness at the loss
of the individualism for the parent the
parents to be present here and all the
relatives mr. Elwell I believe it was
every country grounded the max before we
did every country is it because they
were too quick to draw a conclusion from
two airplanes going down in similar
circumstances and realizing the flying
public should be protected in their
countries or was it because we were just
so much better at using data and not
being concerned with the fact that there
were two identical or closely two at
close to identical crashes how will we
last mr. Cohen as I mentioned earlier
the FAA is data-driven risk-based
systems approach we don't deviate from
that because it's critically important
that that's how we operate you you
mentioned we were the last as far as we
know and we have talked to these
countries who grounded their fleets we
were the first country to ground because
of a data that linked the two accidents
which is critically important to us in
Canada I must say Canada also waited
till we had that data and the data was
not available until the radar tracks
were refined to suggest end and in
evidence we found in the ground that
linked the two flights so the opposite
of data is common sense the other
countries have acted on what looked like
with common sense that there's a causal
connection and a reason to think two
airplanes fall out of the sky and they
crash with similar problems with with
keeping the plane under control after
takeoff in high speeds and that's
because you don't have the data yet
you're jeopardizing another airplane
it just seems my common sense should
have taken control data is fine but
sometimes it's just right before your
eyes
there was a story an article written
that pilots of planes that didn't crash
in the United States kept noticing the
same basic pattern of behavior that is
suspected to have been behind these two
crashes this was in the dáil of Dallas
Morning News review of voluntary
aircraft incident reports than asset
database palace all safely disabled the
end casts and kept their planes of the
air but one of the pilots reported to
the database that it was quote
unconscionable that a manufacturer of
the FAA and the airline's would have
pilots flying an airplane without
adequately training or even providing
available resources of sufficient
documentation to understand the highly
complex systems that differentiate this
aircraft from prior models mr. Dale how
can it be that we didn't tell the pilots
about EM Cass and implore them to be
aware of it in the situation this was
the system that was put in to allow
there to be a home what it was it
arguably a new airplane to compete with
Airbus and we didn't tell the pilots so
mr. Cohen the reports that you're
referring to they're called a SRS it's a
reporting a indemnified safety reporting
system there were in the 50,000 flights
in the max we had 24 reports that
mentioned from pilots that mentioned
some sort of anomaly on pitch
none of those reports were related to
the MKS
zero and so and as I as I mentioned we
scanned and filtered every one of those
flights for evidence that there was M
Cass or AOA vein anomalies in the u.s.
fleet that is what FAA needs to do
that's what we did there were no reports
of MCAS anomalies reported on the max as
has the FA considered requiring that
pilots that fly the max get simulator
training I'm sorry do you mean in the
future that anybody that flies 737 max
that there be a simulator and that they
be trained in that simulator well so we
need to wait for the Boeing application
of the fix once we have the official
application of the fix we'll be able to
determine if and exactly what sort of
training will be required for max pilots
and one last question media reports
indicated that Boeing it underestimated
the capability of them cast by a
magnitude of four times and its initial
submission of the FAA and the FAA only
found about about it from Boeing's
notice to Airlines explaining MCATs
after the lion air accident for the
record can you please confirm this
account and if that's not correct please
clarify the time alone oh I'll get an
answer for you on that question sir I'm
not familiar with with okay we'll put it
our rig check it for the record I yield
back the balance of my time
chair recognizes represent ball derson
for five minutes Thank You mr. chairman
and I also would like to express my
condolences to the families that are
here and my thoughts and prayers are
with you administrator Elwell thank you
for being here today and this important
hearing
there are currently 79 aircraft
certification service OTAs are you aware
of any International Civil Aviation
Organization standards or recommended
practices that directly conflict with
the FF FAA use of the organization
delegation authorization program sir I
am not aware of any I will tell you that
Oda is a practice shared by all
countries
who do certification and in some
countries they use it much more than we
do but I'll please if you let me defer
to to my colleague Earl on that's just
specificity of your question so
delegation is used in universally
throughout the certification process and
in all countries and I guess I would
would highlight that the 737 max was a
dual certification in this case with
EASA the European safety organization
and the FAA and so all the decisions and
review of the delegation and those
activities was conducted by both of the
both agencies at the same time so I
think that shows the reinforcement and
the comfortableness of another Authority
in how we use delegation to assist us
thank you very much administrator Elwell
you state that any party
the FAA regulates remains responsible
for compliance with the eff FAS FAS or
regulatory standards and the FAA does
not hesitate to take enforcement action
when it is warranted can you provide
examples of when faa enforcement action
has taken as a result of non-compliance
and how the FAA was able to discover
violations of your regulatory standards
so there are examples when we have had
to take enforcement action in particular
there have been several actions taken
with Oda I think and Earl will correct
me if I'm wrong I believe that we have
denied Oda authority as sort of a
certificate for Oda and at least one
occasion and then within the Oda
organizations our oversight will
occasionally discover somebody not
following you have to understand that
the organisation itself is run by a
manual that is written specifically for
the activities that the Oda is allowed
to do and when that manual is not
followed then you know will the
oversight catch that will step in but
Earl is there
amplification on that just to build a
little bit on mr. wells comments there
we have removed one OTA but there are
multiple findings as we say it we audit
every single one of these entities on a
annual basis and per the direction of
this committee in our reauthorization
bill you've asked us to stand up a new
Oda oversight office and mr. Elwell
signed off on on setting that office up
in April and that will change us to not
just waiting for an annual basis that
will transition us to a constant
overview of data flow so we'll be
constantly monitoring and not just
relying on annual audit so it will
reinforce that eat to an even greater
extent our oversight alright thank you
both very much I yield back my remaining
time mr. chairman thank you represent
bothersome we were with chair recognizes
reps I'm Titus for five minutes Thank
You mr. chairman
I represent Las Vegas and about half of
the 42 million people come by plane and
so having highest safety standards is
very important when this first happened
though I fly back and forth on Southwest
every weekend first thing I did was call
to see if the flight I had scheduled was
one of these that was in question and I
realized if I'm scared to fly on that I
don't want my family my friends my
constituents or my visitors to fly on
that plane too so it's very important
that we get to the bottom of this so I
thank the chairman for having this
hearing we've heard a lot of Defense
from you this morning about OD AIDS and
the emphasis on data being the reason
you grounded the plane and and that all
sounds fine but the public perception
was that it took so long for us to do it
we were the last ones to do it
is because the FAA was just too cozy
with Boeing that you were in bed with
those that you were supposed to be
regulating and that's why it took so
long so that's the impression the public
has on what we need to deal with now the
emphasis shifts from not the grounding
but the unground
so I would ask you what process you're
going to use to unground at this plane I
know you've created some new
organizations within the agency I think
on the second mr. Elwell you announced
the formation of the joint Authority's
technical review team - that includes a
number of representatives from other
countries - including Ethiopian
Indonesia to investigate your
certification process
last week you announced a multi-agency
technical advisory board to review the
proposed software fix these don't have
regulatory authority but I wonder are
you going to use their decisions before
you move to ungrounded are you gonna
have their consensus what's it going to
look like to the public if you ignore
them when they just become
window-dressing would you address now
the next step thank you ma'am
thank you for that question because it's
very important we have established the
safety record that we have by doing just
what you alluded to listening getting
feedback getting suggestions we've been
incredibly transparent throughout the
process and and that's what we are with
all of the countries we deal with with
the stakeholders in the aviation
industry the tab that you mentioned and
describe perfectly and the jet or the
tab by the way as I mentioned earlier
chairman DeFazio recommended that over
over a month ago and we agreed
wholeheartedly and we will listen in
fact they're in there reviewing right
now we've already received I believe a
couple of a couple of suggestions
we're also on as I mentioned in my
opening remarks were going on May 23rd
to meet with we invited 57 countries
that grounded the max and invited their
Civil Aviation Authority directors to
come and talk to us and us to them more
importantly explaining to them exactly
the process our safety analysis we will
not allow the 737 max to fly in the US
until it is absolutely safe to do so and
we will use
every tool every data gathering
capability we have to ensure that's the
case you have that as a personal
commitment and as a commitment of 45,000
passionate aviation professionals in the
FAA and what role will Boeing play in
this process so Boeing will submit their
application for the update to the MKS
software the formal and final submission
we expect I don't know early next week
or so or and at that point we'll we'll
do test flights we'll do analysis we'll
present it to the tab the tab we'll look
it over we will do a thorough and robust
safety analysis we will determine based
on the software fix they give us will
determine what level of training will be
required of 737 max pilots and then once
we have established all of that and
internally the FAA review says that the
737 max is safe to fly then the prohibit
the prohibition order will be lifted and
we will present whatever mandates are
are tied to this new software and do you
believe you have the resources and the
expertise without depending on the OTAs
to provide that final oversight and make
that guarantee that it's safe to fly
again yes ma'am I do
and how do you reassure us at that and I
point to an organization the FAA s
diligence in safety that has produced a
record that is in many ways remarkable
in the u.s. I also point as I as I just
said the FAA I've never seen outside of
Chairman's own Wealth's organization a
more dedicated organization of safety
professionals I'm awed every day I come
to work they are amazing and I'll tell
you they are
I'm a little bit worried about morale
right now to be honest with you across
the FAA it is critically important to me
that we and of course to the world into
the u.s. that we get this right but it's
important for public confidence like as
you said and it's important for the
morale of the of the great professionals
that are doing the work to get this
airplane safely back in the air and
we're not going to do it until it's safe
thank you thank you miss Jarrell thank
you some tennis I recognize of Massey
for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman I'd like to widen
our focus here a little bit and talk
about the types of data we collect
flight data how we collect it what we do
with it after its collected not just in
these particular incidents but other
incidents because I find it odd that two
weeks thirty days after the incident
there's still speculation and guessing
about what the pilots did how did they
react and we don't know probably just
about everybody in this room has a
camera in their pocket and earlier in
this hearing we saw a picture of a 1967
flight deck of a 737 and versus a 2017
flight deck of a 737 max and I
understand why in 1967 there weren't
cameras in the cockpit can you speak to
why we don't have a cameras in the
cockpit cameras that are cheap and would
answer so many of these questions we're
still speculating about it seems mr. sim
Walt please thank you very much for that
question the NTSB has in fact
recommended that I'm talking about for
commercial flights of course that's
right
cockpit image recorders should be
required for commercial flights we have
four one for airline flights we have
made that recommendation and it has not
been acted upon white way hasn't have
been acted upon well that's a great
question and it's a question that the
regulator should should answer can I ask
you mr. Elwell do you have a thought on
that
so the FAA works with our colleagues at
the NT
be very closely and we take every
recommendation the NTSB makes and we
examine it and we evaluate it for safety
of flight and that is our first and
foremost consideration and German some
weld and I have not always disagreed on
all the recommendations but I think we
would both say that the the this semi
symbiotic relationship that we have has
been part and parcel of where we are
today and the safety record we have
today let me ask about the the way we
collect the data
can you explain to my constituents why
for $10 they can get internet on a
flight for the whole flight yet we're
still chasing down a physical black box
to find out what happened in the cockpit
why do we have to go to the crash site
to recover the data in this day and age
and why is all the data lost if we can't
find the black box miss mr. sim Walt or
miss Schulz if you'd like to ask
answering
sir thank you for that question I'm not
advocating getting rid of the black box
I'm saying why can't we augment it with
some streaming sure and I think the
industry has been looking at this from a
technical standpoint to understand what
is technically feasible but I think that
is something that would be an important
backup to the equipment on the aircraft
which is still a valuable tool and in
these accidents extremely valuable for
us to understand what was going on in
the on the aircraft and in the cockpit
it's hard for me to explain to my
constituents who get on the plane and
get internet why it's not technically
feasible now I know why it wouldn't work
in every situation but and why you need
the black box but let me go to my third
question which is what do we do with the
data after we retrieve it mr. sim wall
why doesn't the NTSB publish all data
from black from the black box
immediately upon retrieval well thank
you very much we do eventually publish
that and let me point out that the NTSB
uses a party system so when we have the
data the
you factor ER has it they shared with
the manufacturer with the FAA with
anybody who needs it to be able to
understand the circumstances of that
crash so that they can make immediate
safe let me let me just appreciate your
answer but I said immediately and you
said eventually okay if we're talking
about public release of the information
yes that does become available when we
open the public docket what why not make
it immediate what what benefit is
conveyed upon society by withholding
that data from the manufacturer the
person who actually made the equipment
why aren't they allowed to have it
immediately and why is the NTSB allowed
to withhold or block them from getting
that data when and I'm talking about the
difference between immediately and
eventually because lives could be lost
eventually all right let me make an
important clarification the manufacturer
and the FAA has access to that
information immediately when we have it
they are a part of our party process
they are in the room reviewing the data
immediately with us I'm glad to have
your assurance on that I have some
manufacturers that have experienced
different results Thank You mr. chairman
thank you recognize represent of Stanton
for five minutes
a very much mr. chairman we're here
today because of the unspeakable loss of
346 lives in the tragic crash of Lion
Air flight 610 he opened flight 302 our
aviation system is the safe in the world
but these accidents have shaken the
public's confidence and trust we owe it
to the people whose lives are lost and
their families to get to the bottom of
what happened and address any issues
within the FAA certification process to
ensure the safety of not only this
aircraft but the system as a whole the
Mac should not be returned to service
until the safety of the aircraft is
assured by FAA Boeing itzhak and its
operators back-to-back crashes demand
the reviews of Boeing nFA's responses
that are underway we need to get to the
bottom of why a single point of failure
was permitted in the max commercial
aviation
the United States is so safe in large
part because of safety redundancies
based on preliminary reports a single
point of failure appears to have played
a significant role in these tragedies
now they're going to reports of certain
optional safety features of the Macs
were sold as extras my question is for
mr. Elwell is it common to have safety
features offered as optional and not
mandatory mr. Stanton
any safety critical component to the
certification of an aircraft is not
optional it's part of the certification
of the aircraft with those features
which were not an either the lion air or
Ethiopian planes have made a difference
in aiding the pylons to more quickly
identify the EM caste system was
triggering in my opinion no I think
you're referring to the AOA disagree
light yes sir
should these should these be required
features I actually would like to defer
to mr. Lawrence please so AOA disagree
indicator has was not on the original
737 it was first introduced on the ng
model it is a maintenance alert so we do
not consider it part of our critical
items and you know not aware of which
aircraft mayor other aircraft may or may
not have it installed as far as you know
what are Boeing's plans to incorporate
these features on all Boeing aircraft
are they looking to incorporate the AOA
indicator and all Boeing aircraft yes
they it is not my understanding as it is
not on other Boeing a aircraft it was
just the ng and in the manner that it
was displayed I understand this the
software modifications for the mcat
system are in process can you describe
the status of the modifications you
would expect for the Macs and then how
confident are you that these will reduce
another incident involving a runway
stabilizer trim event
please let I'll let Earl modify or get
into more detail in the answer but we
are expecting the formal application of
the mem castes update software update
soon we do know the basic parameters of
three pieces to that fix that would in
in once established and once put on
airplanes would render the scenarios
that that were perpetuated in the Lion
air and the Ethiopian accidents they
wouldn't wouldn't happen the way they
happen there but I'll let Earl elaborate
any first part I yes thank you
um the software I would call it the beta
version for this audience here has been
submitted to us and the reason why they
submit it to us is so we can stick it in
the simulator so we can test it so we
can also look at their system safety
analysis and and see whether it will
appropriately address it the key thing
the new software does is look at both
angle of attack indicators to assure
that a single failure will not cause the
system to initiate and future and future
changes our one more question for mr.
Elwell you're a US Air Force Academy
graduate combat pilot during Operation
Desert Storm commercial pilot for 16
years with a combined six thousand
flight hours it's very impressive
experience do you think the FAA should
have mandated training for the mcat
system for pilots knowing what we know
now so thank you for that question
the investigations and the audits and
the review is currently underway are
going to make their recommendations I'm
going to answer you the way you asked
the question as a pilot as somebody who
is devoted my entire life to flying and
safety I at the beginning when I first
heard of this thought that the M cast
should have been more adequately
explained in the ops manual on the
flight manual absolutely we in our
emergency air worthiness directive that
we issued on November 8th after Lyon air
we added explanation of M casts and we
also reminded our own operators in the
world via document with kala Kanak we
reminded pilots that when to engage
runaway pitch trim procedures and we and
we added a note to those instructions
when we complete our overview when we
complete our safety analysis I expect
that we will have amplified M casts
description in addition to anything else
that we think and we find is needed to
make pilots more aware and and respond
better to an anomaly thank you thank you
thank you we're gonna proceed on our
side of the aisle with questions and
then if there's a member of the
Republican Party that shows up that
hasn't asked questions and they'll get
in line and appropriate time so we'll go
with Nexis representative resident craig
recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman I too want to
express my sincere condolences to the
members the family members are here
today for the lives that were lost mr.
Elwell as you may know before I came to
Congress I worked similar in a similarly
highly regulated space the medical
device industry where one malfunctioning
defibrillator or piece mater maker could
result in an innocent life lost we
heated strict compliance and reporting
requirements to disclose aftermarket mal
actions to the government through the
FDA's adverse event reporting system
this aftermarket reporting was and
continues to be justified with that in
mind I'd like to learn more about the
manufacturer aftermarket reporting
requirements that allow the FAA to be
notified about certain failures
malfunctions or defects because
according to media reports Boeing first
discovered that the angle of attack
sensor disagree light software was
malfunctioning a few months after
delivery of the Macs in May of 2017 at
that time they learned the disagree
light wouldn't work unless airlines also
had the optional AOA indicators
therefore eighty percent of pilots
flying Boeing's Mac's believed an
indicator light would show when in fact
it would not but it wasn't until Lyon
air in October of 2018 over a year later
that Boeing finally notified FAA that
most planes were flying with software
malfunctions furthermore the New York
Times reported yesterday that pilots
from American Airlines pressed Boeing
executives to work urgently on a fix in
a closed-door meeting they even argued
that Boeing should push authorities to
take an emergency measure that would
likely result in the grounding of the
Mac's so with that I have three
yes-or-no questions and then I have a
fourth did Boeing have an obligation to
report this after market software
malfunction to the FAA owing software
engineers did write a per a a PR what is
the the performance report problem
problem report okay followed there they
followed their procedures because it is
not that AOA disagree the light was not
a critical safety display its advisory
only for maintenance recording it
languished and and I I am NOT happy with
13 months 13 month gap between finding
that anomaly and us finding out about it
and we're going to look into that we are
looking into that
and and we will make sure that software
anomalies are reported more quickly so
that was a yes did Boeing have an
obligation to report this aftermarket
software malfunction to existing airline
customers for them to be aware of and
submit a service difficulty report if
necessary did Boeing have that
responsibility yes or no I'm sorry can
you repeat the question I didn't get the
beginning yet did they have an
obligation to report this aftermarket
software malfunction to existing airline
customers is there an obligation on
their part to report this malfunction to
consumers as well so the Boeing Oda and
the Boeing software engineers respond to
their procedures I'm going to defer to
Earle on whether or not they that the
standards and the and the OTA manual
requires that the obligation is to be
evaluated eight the anomaly to the
internationally approved standards and
procedures for looking at that if those
procedures indicate that it's in the
item that meets a certain level then yes
it would have to be reported to the
other airlines and to the FAA in this
particular case the approved procedures
designated the risk of this item not
being in a working condition was did not
require immediate action it did require
action and that's what we were talking
about we would like to see quicker
reaction than 13 months and in the
future and can you can you confirm mr.
Elwell that Boeing continued to deliver
planes with a non-functioning disagree
like even after the discovery that it
was only operational with add-ons and
even after the lion air accident I
believe that the 727 max was delivered
after the software engineers discovered
that anomaly yes thank you and finally
do you believe our current aftermarket
reporting requirements are adequate to
protect airline passengers miss Cregg
we have an IG report we have the
blue-ribbon panel of the Special
Committee we have the chatter that we
formed we have this committees
investigation has been initiated and
we're gathering reams and reams of data
all of these reviews are going to look
at the process top to bottom and come
back with recommendations I fully expect
that when this is all done we are going
to have recommendations that will make
us better in addition we're going to
continue to scrutinize our process we're
going to make sure that it doesn't take
13 months to find out that there's a
software anomaly but I I just want to
remind everyone here let's not make the
AOA disagree light the issue the a way
disagree light is an advisory and the
AOA disagree light would not have
changed in either accident I want to
make sure everybody understands don't
don't make something that isn't a
critical safety item a critical safety
item because there are enough critical
safety items for us to focus on thank
you I yield back chair recognizes
represent Davids the vice chair of the
subcommittee for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman and I too would
like to extend my condolences to the
family members who have lost loved ones
and are here today and I think it's
really important for us to recognize
that the relationship that exists
between this committee and the FAA and
the NTSB is one that is clearly geared
toward making sure that we are operating
the safest airline industry aerospace
industry and and our Airways here in
this country and I'm I've been very
happy to hear the desire for just an
evaluation of where are the things that
we can actually address to make sure
that no matter what these types of
tragedies don't occur in the future
and you know as a member of this this
committee I take
constitutional duty of oversight very
seriously and I know that you take FA
A's duty to safety very seriously as
well and because of that I want to take
a step back and ask how often and you
mentioned in your testimony that the
regulations and safety certification
procedures are constantly reevaluated
can you talk a little bit about how
often the process is really weighted to
make sure that we're that when new
technologies are coming along and and
we've got new standards that might be
developing how often are we evaluating
the actual process of the certifications
thank you for that question the FAA is
an organization is constantly collecting
data evaluating data taking action and
reviewing it's the safety management
system approach to everything we do it
is never static
having said that we don't change just to
change we we pull data we review we
analyze data we do this both internally
and we do it externally we have what's
called an I don't I don't know how far
you want me to go into this but we have
an organization called the commercial
aviation safety team that was formed in
1997 the goal there was to gather data
from all stakeholders in the commercial
aviation ecosystem and to collect all
that data voluntarily and analyze that
data come up with safety enhancements
since 1997 we've generated over a
hundred voluntary safety enhancements
the entire industry uses and they use
them to this day and we've reduced the
commercial aviation fatality rate by
ninety five percent since 97
and that is exactly from what you just
asked from analyzing our processes
gathering data coming up with solutions
implementing those solution
and then evaluating the results of that
implementation and then can I'd actually
like to hear about the the exchange of
information between the NTSB and and FAA
earlier you mentioned that when the NTSB
has gone through and looked at some of
the probably some of the previous
accidents that at least on one occasion
a recommendation to include video
recordings in the cockpit has been made
how often are the who's making the
decision about which recommendations by
the NTSB are being adopted into the
safety protocols and can you talk a
little bit about what that process looks
like is that maybe maybe a little bit
about how are the recommendations made
and then how do you decide whether or
not you're going to accept those
recommendations right I'll make it quick
the NTSB investigates transportation
accidents and when we find areas that
could could enhance safety as a result
of that accident or crash we issue
safety recommendations we issue them to
the appropriate recipient we issue for
aviation accidents more than likely they
would go to the regulator who of course
is the FAA in this case and we receive
the NTSB recommendations and then we
have to go through a process to evaluate
those recommendations against the the
whole system
chairman some what we've had this
conversation they have sometimes the
envía bill enviable luxury of looking at
at a single event or a single issue we
take every recommendation in its
totality for the whole system and that's
why we continue to collaborate and and
we continue to evaluate all the
recommendations for and for implement
what for to determine whether or not
they can be implemented but that the
unifying thing between NTSB and FAA
is an unshakable desire to improve this
system and make the system safer sure
recognizes resent Brownlee for five
minutes
Thank You mr. chairman I too want to
express my condolences to the family
who's here today my daughter lives in
Africa and has lived and worked in
Africa for the last five years she's
lived in a couple of different places
she lived in Nairobi and my daughter has
taken this flight from Addis Ababa many
many times so this particular crash
really hit me hard and my gut but my
condolences to you I also wanted to
follow up on the camera in the cockpit
cockpit suggestion so you make the
suggestion to the regulator but none of
those suggestions are made public that
doesn't come to Congress thank you for
that question
we do not issue recommendations directly
to Congress
however when Congress asked for our
input we do in fact provide a list of
all all open recommendations and
thankfully oftentimes those
recommendations end up getting folded
into legislation and then when the FAA
doesn't agree with recommendations does
that report come to Congress ma'am I
don't think so I don't think so but I
will check I'll check and make sure
thank you mr. Elwell in your testimony
you talked about you stated that any
party that the FAA regulates remains
responsible for compliance with the FAA
z' regulatory standards and the FAA does
not hesitate to take enforcement action
when it is warranted so was there ever a
time through the 737 max certification
that enforcement was warranted the 737
max certification began in January 2012
ended in March 17 forever five years
ever warranted to I love the first girl
if we've if we took enforcement action
specifically on anything with regard to
the max um I do not believe we took any
enforcement action regarding the max
during that five years what would have
happened because it was a certification
activity as anytime we would have gotten
any concerns from any of the engineers
that were working it we would have
evaluated those and addressed them right
then and there before the final
certification okay but there in terms of
some of this self certification process
that's part of the certification process
there was never a need to take any
enforcement action um
no yes or no I've got a lot of question
up for these okay very good
also mr. Elwell in your testimony you
say the FAA identifies all safety
standards identifies all safety
standards and makes all key decisions
regarding certification of the aircraft
so from your perspective does that
ultimately mean that the Box the buck
stops with you yes ma'am it does thank
you
also in the in your testimony you talked
about the process for certification
included 297 certification flight tests
and you say then some of which encompass
tests of the MCAS functions can you tell
me how many times that that was tested
you gave the number for the overall
process but not for the EM castle as to
297 flights a hundred and thirty three
we flew and the others we we contributed
in some way or another it I don't know
the number of test flights where the M
casts was about you had that in a record
somewhere we'd certainly would have that
and get that back to you yes okay very
good
you also went on in your testimony to
talk about secretary Chao
the u.s. Department's Inspector General
report you have any idea when that
report will be available to the public I
think you're referring to the IG report
she directed on certification I can't I
don't want to set a date for for the IG
but I generally those investigations
take 9 to 18 months
thank you secretary Chao also announced
the establishment of a special committee
to review the FHA's procedures for
certification you stated that that will
be presented directly to the secretary
and the FAA Administrator what about to
the public into Congress typically this
the special committee that will be
formed under the sokak it it is for lack
of a better term a blue-ribbon panel and
in and in my experience over my career
blue-ribbon panel
results are often made public but I
won't speak for the secretary as to how
those results will be disseminated but I
can again get that answer for you
absolutely thank you I have more
questions
sheriff kinases represent already for
five minutes I think you missed a
chairman and I think store panels for
being here
I represent Dallas which is home to
Southwest Airlines and American Airlines
two of our best airlines here in the
country who've also invested heavily in
737 max we also have Boeing in our area
and I recognize the investment that
they've made in this and the price that
it's costing our airlines the the
grounding of the max and also of course
recognize what this is doing to Boeing
but I think that our role on this
committee and your role obviously as I
know you agree at the FAA is that our
our motivation for being here is that we
want to make sure that our airspace is
the safest in the world that we continue
to be the gold standard I've been asked
a lot about the Macs in Dallas and then
I always say that you know we still are
the gold center for safety and then we
will remain that and so my questioning
in these next couple minutes is getting
at making sure we maintain that because
when we spoke back in March when you
briefed us in a private
briefing I mentioned to you reports from
pilots concern with concerns of being
raised about the max and you kind of
downplayed some of those and then as the
Dallas Morning News recently reported
and as some of my colleagues have
mentioned a recording between the
American Airlines pilot Union and Boeing
on November 27th 2018 the pilots
expressed a number of concerns to the
Boeing executives and my question to you
is was the FAA made aware by Boeing or
by anyone else about that meeting or
about any of the pilots concerns well
thank you for that question mr. Allred
my first indication of that meeting was
was when I read about it in the article
and I can't obviously I can't speak to a
private meeting I will tell you this
though my understanding is that meeting
happened not long after the lion air
accident and I will tell you as a
lifelong pilot that when an accident
happens anywhere and it's and it's it
includes an airplane you fly it becomes
visceral it's a it's a it's it's an
emotional response pilots who fly an
airplane when they see when go down and
I would imagine that there was
heightened emotions in that meeting I
will tell you that when I was briefed
and they explained the lion air and what
we the data we gathered and told me
about the MCATs and I learned that it
wasn't explained in the manual my my my
my pilot juices started flowing and I
said well we let's look in we need to
look into that so I I don't I don't
discount what what was reported in that
meeting and I and I understand it but I
can't comment on it what was said in the
meeting okay do you know for there were
any OD a designee is present at that
meeting for Boeing I have I have no idea
okay if not should there be a
requirement placed on manufacturers like
Boeing to disclose the concerns of
pilots when they're presented in a
fashion like that should the FAA have
been made aware of that
my sir my initial reaction to that
question would be any time a
manufacturer that the FAA has regulatory
oversight over becomes aware of a
critical safety item it should be made
known to the FAA and I'll defer to Earl
if that's actually part of a regulator
is actually a regulatory requirement
that if they become aware of anything
that's critical to safety they need to
disclose that to to us so after one
crash when a major American airline
major pilot union is expressing their
concerns that should have been raised to
FA I again if it is a critical safety of
flight item either I was I would say
just you know I'm not a pilot I would
say though if we've hadded a crash and
our professional pilots here
domestically are expressing their
concerns that's something that the FAA
should know about and so I think that
that's something we need to look at here
in Congress to make sure that you have
that information as quickly as possible
if I could add mr. Olver that's the same
at around that same time since the line
air accident and forward to today my
communications I happened to have been a
allied pilot association member for 16
years I had regular conversations with
the leadership of the Southwest Airline
Pilots Association the Allied Pilots
Association and the airline pilot
Association on a regular basis because
we thrive on transparency we thrive on
communication and I had regular
conversations with them including an
April 12th meeting where we brought in
the unions of all three of our us
operators of the Macs and their flight
departments and we had a give-and-take
for about two and a half hours well
thank you and just mr. chairman for the
record if we could I'd like to have an
answer on on the MCATs not being in the
manual and how how the decision was
reached by the fa not to require that if
you could submit that for the record I'd
appreciate that sir well the record so
we'll proceed with the second round of
questioning
and I'll recognize myself for five
minutes and go to mr. sim wall and Miss
Schultz with regards to the et 302
report as an example of how we work in a
supporting manner and as opposed to lead
are the things in the 83 302 report that
you would characterize differently if
you were writing it well I'll take a
stamp of that and then Dana mentioned it
the Ethiopian government has not had the
number of investigations that we've had
and I say that not in a bragging manner
but we've been in business for a long
time they have not had many major
accidents in Ethiopia so they don't have
the level of experience that we do again
I'm not bragging nor making a
condescending statement it's just a fact
as a result of that they are moving very
cautiously and very deliberately and so
as far as the rest of that I'll help
defer to Dana thank you for the question
chairman Larson and in fact we're very
pleased that the Ethiopian government
did release a report publicly that
information was critically important of
course to the FAA and Boeing but it was
also critically important to other
airlines flying the aircraft and and
frankly other regulators worldwide to
understand all the factors with that
said as with we see in many preliminary
reports issued by different countries
there perhaps not exactly as the NTSB
would format the information or produce
it but I would say that the preliminary
report is just that it's the information
that was available at the time and so I
would caution that that's not everything
by any stretch and some of that
information will need to be expanded
further and we are of course working
very closely with the Ethiopian
government to make sure that that we
contribute as and participate in that
work does IKEA provide a rubric for a
standard format for the reporting for
developing and for developing actually
and for actually reporting the results
of the
ignition yes the the short answer to
that is yes ICAO annex 13 outlines the
standards and recommended practices and
to your satisfaction in the case of ET
302 the ethiopian government is
following those standards and practices
they are but daenam was just in Ethiopia
last week and I think she could further
elaborate yes they are following the
annex 13 practice and we as a state our
state of manufacturer have our
accredited representative as part of the
investigation along with our advisors
and so I was in Addis to to meet with
the investigative agency to reinforce
the u.s. support and our participation
in the follow-on investigation at this
point that will go forward so yes they
are following the process and we are
going to continue to work closely with
them on that in all the all areas so in
the case of the lion air and Ethiopia
I guess when we apply our standard of
timelines we tend to think it takes a
year to get a final report out from NTSB
about you better take dissipate it'll be
a year for a lion air report and a year
from the crash for the ET 3:02 report
yes in the case of lion air they have
said that they would they're planning to
get the report out by the 12-month
anniversary as far as Ethiopian it's
very early in in the stage for Ethiopia
and I we couldn't say but the the
Indonesian government is planning to
have report released in towards the fall
administer el well regarding next week's
meeting in next week in Dallas with the
directors general what do you what do
you what is the phase goal in this
meeting thank you for that question sort
of the the goal is to offer all of these
countries who have grounded or
prohibited flight in their airspace 737
max the benefit of
all the information and all the thinking
we as the state of design have to offer
them it has been mentioned several times
in this hearing that there is the
perception at least of a crisis and
confidence particularly with regard to
the airplane and maybe maybe larger it
is my hope that we get to in a way sort
of fix a process that didn't in my
opinion go in a way that we're used to
internationally on the initial at the
accident internationally we are
collaborative 99% of the time when the
Ethiopian accident happened it was not a
collaborative process from Sunday night
to Wednesday morning despite our best
efforts and attempts to have
conversations
I know countries act and they act for
various reasons this on the ungrounded I
think it's just critically important
that as a global aviation community we
do what we do best we collaborate we
exhibit transparency we answer the
questions that that I'm sure these
countries are going to have of us and
then at the end of the day and it will
be literally a day long
agenda and regimen with them my hope is
that they have a confidence in our work
in our analysis to make their on
grounding decisions if if that's where
the discussion is as close to our
decision as possible because I think
that's important for for the world to
have some level of confidence thank you
I didn't notice two members